let's say we're talking here in
Luxembourg but of course the ftth
asia-pacific has a massive event coming
up in May tell us how the planning is
going for that right thank you Brian yes
so we have our event taking place
between 17 and 18 min in Bangkok we
expect it to be pretty large event as
usual and we have a full support from
the local operators they're going to
come and participate we are having
participations for new some new
countries that are getting into FTTH so
we were expecting Cambodia represented
from Cambodia Myanmar Laos and others
we've invited them so we expect the IPS
from Deb coming in we also have a very
good nice panels set up of good 40 to 50
speakers from the industry including
very recently confirmed from google so
we expect somebody very senior from
google coming in and joining us so it
should be a very exciting event for us
that's amazing that's amazing now I'm
hearing all the time the Asia is leading
the world in FTTH deployment you know
what's your what's your perception of
the market at the moment well as you
know last year we we hit the 100 million
mark and it came off on a celebration of
the 10-year of formation of the f th
Council asia-pacific and then we are
really excited that we are you know 100
million and then ticking still it's just
still coming very strong we were from
the council side you know we are working
on a lot of the new applications and
solutions that we're seeing evolving in
the market such as the ng pawn to we're
also looking at you know deployments
such as in open access networks so these
are some of the interesting things that
are happening in Asia Pacific at this
moment that's how the work of the
council helps the industry move forward
what kind of things you get involved
with right so so recently you know we
have formed a couple of new committees
one of them being the smart cities
committee another one that we're working
on is fiber as a service committee these
are there to provide white papers we
talked about the best practices best
standards and that provides some sort of
a kind
to you know the industry as to how the
ftth is evolving and in a lot of the
other services that are coming in and
that's how the council contributes to to
the industry so you're confident that
you're going to help keep a few right at
the cutting edge well you know the way
we look at it we are way ahead in
numbers and we'll keep on adding more
numbers to it year by year and then so
it's at 100 million and beyond fantastic
thanks very much for talking to us and
best of luck for the event in May thank
you very much Brian